and the left-hander jordan montgomery
will pitch for the yankees he's three
and one
his era is four points 20. here's matt
chapman
he was pushed up to second in the order
today
he's hitting just 224 and he's a much
much better hitter than that but it's 20
21 average
eight homers and 32 rbis now here's the
one
two pitch cutout of miss
chapman strikes out two out olson's
coming up
here's the delivery 100 to matt and
swung on a high fly ball
center field deep judge is going back at
the track does he have room he leaps
and he runs out of room and olson has
homer to center field
and the athletics take a one-nothing
lead
and first inning long balls for the a's
all three games of this series
one nothing is on olson's 20th home run
shawn minaya who's been great for the
a's
overall six and two and a 299 era but in
his last five starts he's three and oh
with an 084
here's judge who's batting 283. here's
the o2 pitch on the way swung out of
miss a high fastball strikes him out
94 miles an hour on a high fastball
judge goes after it
that'll bring up john carlos stanton
here it is and the fastball ring him up
he takes it ring him up strike three
call
stanton case sanchez left his second and
after one these lead the yankees one
nothing
here's sean murphy with the o2 struck
him out swinging breaking ball in the
dirt
second strikeout for monty three up
three down at the end of an inning and a
half one nothing open
torres one freight on the series a
right-handed hitter
here's the 0-2 pitch swung onto miss a
high fast ball
strikes him out so torres k's that'll
bring up g.o
urshella who's batting at nine homers
and 31 rbis and the delivery and here's
the 2-2 again
and swung out of miss and a fast ball
away perfect pitch
two out glad he stayed with the fastball
because her cello is not getting around
on the fastballs that shawn was throwing
in never want to speed up the hitters
back
one on one out and now back to the top
of the order
and here is marcanna
and here's montgomery's payoff pitch
struck him out swinging high fastball
strikeout number three for montgomery so
first and second two men on here's the
home run hitter
matt olson rhinos first and second chew
out
lefty to lefty montgomery to olson and
the pitch is swung on hit high in the
air to right
frazier cutting over toward the line
near the wall
makes a catch right at the wall
well the yankees better figure out how
not to pitch to olson
he just missed a three-run home run
frazier caught it with his glove
up right near the top of the wall no
runs one hit
two left end of two and a half taking a
flyer on uh
gideon's trying to provide some offense
for the club
the wine the 3-2 and a swing and a miss
just came back and challenged him
and gets his fifth strike out of the day
here comes clint frazier
and he used a good fastball 94 miles an
hour and that is six strikeouts for
mania
swinging a miss and down goes frazier
down goes frasier
down goes frasier down goes frasier
and that's six strikeouts and now here's
judge who struck out
back in the first inning and the 2-2
best ball swing and a miss high octane
at
finishes off aaron judge seven
strikeouts
through three innings for shamania out
of the fourth inning one nothing open
now one doubt here is jed lowry a switch
hit a batting right
and the dodgers will be in arizona
arizona's lost
16 straight 2-2 cut on it miss
lowry whiffs that's the fourth strikeout
for montgomery
one nothing is bottom of the fourth
inning and gleber torres stands in
the 2-2 swing and a miss fastball away
beauty of a sinker at 94. that's eight
k's for mania
he has really been dominant so far this
afternoon
on the fifth inning and the ace leaded
one to nothing
now here's the other elvis on the way
and he chases a change up and down he
goes
well two down here is the rookie catcher
aramis
garcia who singled his first time one
two struck him out swinging so
montgomery's not doing bad he has six
strikeouts in five innings
and he's given up one run on two hits
l'oreal at first and here's jed lowery
switch hitter batting left
now here's a 3-2 to lowry
[Applause]
a ground ball to first gittens to the
bag
to end the inning no runs one hit
and two left at the end of five and a
half and that'll bring up le mayhew
who's bounced out in double
now sean shakes off a sign now ready
at the belt and here's the pitch and
that's on the outside
corner perfect pitch ring him up lemay
who knew it
he heads back to this i got 11
strikeouts for sean minaya
career high for him first and second
with one man
out for sanchez that one's driven out
into right center field and deep on the
run is loriento he can't get there it'll
be one hop against the wall
frazier scores here comes judge here's
the throw
he'll score sanchez going to third he'll
be
tagged out no he's safe he's safe in the
yankees league two to one
yeah he's in there and he is in there
glamour one for 10 on the series sergio
throws it's a swinging a ground ball to
third right to chat but he's got it
fires over to first with the out romo
does the job
it keeps this a one run deficit but the
yankees get two they leave sanchez at
third and after
six yankees lead the a is two to one not
only is moreland a good left-hand hitter
but he is
over the years expert and getting big
hits driving in runs
lives ago will deal 2-2 to moreland
struck him out swinging so lewisga gets
the job done no runs no hits one left
at the end of six and a half well here's
lorianna with the tying run at third
and now two out now the o2
swung on a fly ball to left frazier
going back
he's there to make the catch just
on the edge of the uh of the track near
the yankee
visitors bullpen here's the catch of
sean murphy
run his lead at first and second no one
out pitch
hit on the ground at third ashelah steps
on the back goes to second two
onto first a triple play a triple play
ball game over yankees win
[Music]
yankees win
the second such triple play in the last
few days